don't stay in tomorrow you've got to add
some points move from tomorrow to right
now you can't just sit at home and
imagine a Lamborghini and it pulls up
into the driveway somebody gives you the
keys what if your default emotions was
gratitude all the time what if it was
joy all the time now you might get
pushed and get stressed out for a minute
but you come back to joy what doesn't
kill you does make you stronger that
doesn't mean it doesn't hurt it hurts
but it makes you stronger he's been a
leader in the network marketing industry
for almost 30 years he's built a sales
organization totaling over 500,000
distributors in over 60 countries he's
the author of the international
bestseller book
Go Pro he's Eric quarry and here's my
take on his top 10 rules to success rule
number three is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys
liked the best and as always guys as
you're watching the videos if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it to other people
can be inspired as well also as you are
writing something down it's much more
likely to stick in your head to enjoy
[Music]
tomorrow someday
next week I'm about to this is the
language that I hear a lot in network
marketing tomorrow I'm going to get
started tomorrow I'm going to schedule
some appointment after the weekend I'm
really going to kick it when the new
month starts I'm going to make it happen
once I get past this birthday then I'm
really going to take off once the kids
get out of school then I'm going to
focus on this once the kids get back
into school after the summer break that
I'm going to do it after the holidays
then I want to make it happen now here's
the thing people do a lot of talking and
one side of proclaiming what you're
going to do is very good telling the
world what you're about to do stop
telling them something that you haven't
done yet that's a very healthy thing
because it will hold you accountable to
those statements but don't get stuck
there
don't stay in tomorrow you've got to at
some point move from tomorrow to right
now move from the action that you're
going to do on Monday to right now not
even today because that gives you all
the time until the end of the day you've
got to move your clock when you think
about here's one thing I need to do I
need to schedule more appointments I'm
going to do that right now right now the
first available moment I have to do it
I'm going to do it right now I'm going
to start right now I'm going to get
moving right now because a lot of you
are listening to this stuff and that's
great listening is great understanding
is even better action is even better
than understanding you can have the most
knowledgeable person in the world but if
they keep saying tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow they're never going to
get the results that they're looking for
so guess where most of the learning and
most of the real understanding comes
from in the doing a lot of people think
that they understand network marketing
and they can never understand what it is
that you do
every day because they've never done it
you understand really on a cellular
level when you do it and if you continue
with action you'll start to get results
from those actions because it's not just
in the doing once it's the doing and
then refining and doing again and then
refining work getting better every
single day
understanding that you can't look good
and get better at the same time being
willing to be uncomfortable being
willing to get out of side of your
comfort zone being willing to go from a
tomorrow person to a right now person my
future plan is about this thick tight
it's usually about 40 pages or so and it
includes everything and today more than
ever will you find with top leaders will
your time find with successful people is
there forward-thinking there future
thinking and that that future starts to
pull them towards those objectives so I
set my goals pretty high and I've set my
calendar far in advance I'm planning I
still have some spontaneity room for
spontaneity but more and more as the the
the demands on my time are growing
exponentially I have to plan and and
what I've done this for gosh 25 years to
look back and look forward look back
take inventory be honest and look
forward and map it out so I want you to
think about short-term mid-term
long-term goals for you personally and
for your team create an environment that
supports your goals your dreams what I
need by that make sure the people around
you are pushing you in the direction of
your dreams not patting you on the back
for doing less than you're capable but
pushing you to do more make sure the
things you're feeding your mind are
pushing you in the direction of your
dreams make
that you're protecting your mind from
things that will distract you from your
dreams it's your job it's your job to
create a bubble to create an environment
to create this ecosystem that will
support your goals because if if you're
surrounded by people that are constantly
distracting you it's going to be very
difficult for you to grow a network
marketing business if you're surrounded
by people who are patting you on the
back for doing one tenth of what you're
capable of instead of pushing you and
challenging you and getting in your face
then there's only so far you can go if
you're constantly feeding your mind and
allowing your mind to be infected by
negative pessimistic compromising
thoughts then you can guess what your
results are going to be so gessen job
it's not you're not trying to look for
an environment that will support you you
your job is to create an environment
that will support you create this
community around you create the right
friendships the right mentoring the
right coaching the right ideas the right
encouragement the right challenge for
you to be able to go where you need to
go no sound a thing so it's your job to
hold yourself accountable and create
systems to hold yourself accountable to
a higher standard your dreams are worth
it I promise if you're frustrated you
don't know why you can't take action
this is the big reason why you can't
seem to get things going this is why so
one determine those strings get them
lock solid to hold yourself accountable
towards them and three creating system
around you of people and influences
around you that will challenge you that
will push you that will force you
sometimes to do the things necessary to
make your dreams a reality I've had to
evolve so many times I've had to change
and grow so many times
there's been times when I made such huge
mistakes in my network marketing career
damaged relationships done things that I
wish I could go back and change but I
couldn't so I could either live there or
I could use that information to grow and
become better see I've been involved for
25 years and I promise you every year
then you that we're engaged we're
working together every year you're going
to see me get a little bit better and a
little bit better and most of the time
I'm not going to hit my goals but then
I'm going to get a little bit better and
a little bit better and compounded over
time you'll see noticeable results
anybody knows we know that I'm a
different person than it was five years
ago ten years ago 15 years ago certainly
25 years ago 18 jobs you know barely
surviving so give yourself some grace
understand that nothing is ever finished
while you're still alive but here's what
I believe is the most powerful force one
of the most powerful forces on earth and
that is your imagination what you can
imagine
now most people misuse their imagination
in other words they think about what bad
things could happen they let their
imagination go wild to the negative side
how they could get hurt how they could
get rejected what could you know all the
terrible things that could happen but
the most successful people and and I
will tell you I've used this in my life
for my whole life and it's about my
whole adult career at least and it's
worked unbelievable is using your
imagination for good using it for growth
now here's what I what I what I mean by
that if you pick a goal whatever it is
let's say you want to meet someone let's
say you want to achieve a rank let's say
you want to get to an income goal let's
say you want to have a certain number of
people in your group at the next company
event whatever it is okay I want you to
clearly imagine it get it so clear in
your mind that it's like you're living
it in reality what does it look like
what does it feel like what does it
smell like what does it taste like as
clear as you can get it and when you're
talking about what the
what this this this picture in your mind
it's good to put it in writing and it's
good to make it as detailed as you
possibly can how do you feel now that
you've achieved that goal how many lives
are you impacting now that you've
accomplished that objective whatever it
is no matter what it is but the key is
detailed the key is specific the key is
a clear crystal clear mental picture so
get it clear and then just go about your
life but his here's what what ends up
happening and it happened to me so many
times you can't even imagine as soon as
I get it clearly in my mind it's not
long before that thing becomes a reality
now it's not a magic trick okay you
can't just sit at home and imagine a
Lamborghini and it pulls up into the
driveway somebody gives you the keys
it's not a magic trick like that here's
why I believe it works your subconscious
brain is working all the time no matter
what you're doing it's working it's
helping you guide and shift and make
different decisions but if you get a
clearer picture in your mind
I believe you unlock the power of your
subconscious mind and when you unlock
the power of your subconscious mind it
starts to grind and grind and grind and
grind to make the picture that you have
in your imagination a reality and there
starts to be thousands of what I like to
call micro decisions that start to
happen
little left turn right turn little
course corrections thousands of them
that are happening all the time while
you sleep your subconscious brain is is
working to help you guide you towards
that objective if you're mulling along
if you're doing the laundry yet
subconscious mind is working if your
imagination is strong enough and clear
enough your subconscious mind is working
and working and grinding and grinding
and moving it's not like you're
attracting those things to you you're
attracting yourself to those things
because
your subconscious mind is working for
you it's like a slave for you working
and grinding and working and grinding
and working and grinding to help you get
to your objective thousands and
thousands of little decisions you didn't
know why you made them they were made
because one you had a clear picture in
your mind to your subconscious brain
went to work without you even realizing
it
and three step by step inch by inch you
move closer to your objective until you
attained it so the picture that you have
in your mind is incredibly important
because guess what if you have a
negative picture in your mind a negative
picture in your imagination your
subconscious mind is going to go to work
to make that a reality to thousands of
little micro decisions to guide you
towards the negative so who wants to
live with that who wants to put your
subconscious mind to work as your
employee to work for you and work
against you why would you want to do
that so get a clear picture of your
goals of your objectives of your vision
of anything you want to accomplish
anyone that you want to meet anything
that you want to do I've envisioned
getting our stage that I wanted to speak
on I've been I've envisioned having
thousands of people in the room I've
envisioned relationships with top of my
heroes in personal development with Jim
realms and the Tony Robbins and the
Richard Branson's and all the different
people I've imagined those relationships
long before they became a reality and
then my subconscious mind went to work
and it ground and it was grinding and
grinding and grinding and grinding
thousands of decisions until it became a
reality
so one think of something that's
important to you get it clear in your
mind and then let your subconscious mind
grind for you let it work for you let it
create results for you in this book the
one that I was just reading over the
weekend he talks about the fact that you
know what if times are bad for you right
now if the wind is blowing in your face
right now just hang in there because the
wind can change the wind will change it
if the winds in your face
the wind can change and be on your back
and be on your back and propel you
forward and and I really struggled with
this message I really had a difficult
time with it because I listened to so
much of Jim Rohn and because if you if
you know anything at all which I'm an
amateur but if you know anything at all
about sailing it doesn't matter what the
wind is doing if it's at your back or if
it's in your face there is a way for you
to move forward if the wind is in your
face and you have a sailboat you just go
back and forth and back and forth using
that same wind to go forward I will tell
you there's a group of people who are
crossing their fingers today and they're
waiting for the wind to change there's a
group of people who are hoping and
praying that the wind changes and what I
want to tell all of you if your if any
of those those who are you is you don't
need to wait for the wind to change the
wind which ever way it blows can be your
friend if it's in your face you have a
different approach to how you move
forward if it's on the side you have a
different approach to how you move
forward if it's at your back there's
going to be times when it's at your back
sure everybody can move forward quickly
when the winds at your back but when
it's not and it's not most of the time
you have to have a strategy to move
forward we can change the sail and we
can have total control regardless of the
wind we can decide which direction we're
going to go regardless of the wind we
don't have to wait for something out
there to happen in order for us to be
okay it's not out there ladies and
gentlemen it's in here it's not out
there it's in here so not only do you
need to take charge when it comes to
setting the sail of your life we need to
let the whole world know while they're
all waiting for this wind to change and
it might and engaging of course at some
point it's going to change but it may
not change for some people for a long
time we can give them an opportunity and
the skills to be able to prosper
regardless of the direction of the WIMP
you get what I'm saying to you it's not
out there ladies and gentlemen it's
right in here once you get that you
realize how much power you actually
really have in controlling the direction
of your life everything will change for
you instead of focusing just on the how
one of the skills not only just the
tactical skills of how to do things but
the skills of understanding the human
element of what it is that we do if you
know why you need to use your own
product or service every single day then
it's easy to develop structures for
everybody to learn how to do that if you
know why it's important to build your
story if you know why it's important to
go to your event if you know why it's
important to share the opportunity
that's know if you know why it's
important to utilize third party tools
if you know why it's important to be
able to give a strong testimonial if you
know why it's important to focus on
personal development then the how-to
gets easy and and if you know why and
you get that why strong enough you can
help all of those people that have been
in assignment oriented living for their
whole life in other words they've been
doing what they're told their whole life
a lot of people are waiting for somebody
like you who understands why it is that
we do what we do to be able to inspire
those people to start to do it to do the
how-to and then eventually they'll
develop the y21 tie or understood this
concept of the why the person knows how
to do something will always work for the
person knows why do something well I
don't want to work for anybody the rest
of my life what I want to do is I want
to focus on why am i doing everything
why does this work in network marketing
why does this not work in network
marketing I understood all of the
mechanical psychological triggers that
made our business
just work and once I understood the
why's that not only did the house get
easy for me but it became very easy for
me to inspire other people to take
action because I understood the true
reasons why to do something I wasn't
just saying do it because I said so I
could explain that philosophy to them I
switched my mind from becoming the best
how-to guy that you would ever meet to
becoming the best y2 guy that you'll
ever meet
change my business changed my life I
will tell you if you implement this in
your business little changers too and
can't afford to mow your lawn what does
that title even mean let me back up and
give you some context to it and I think
by the end of this show you're going to
agree with me if you're involved in
network marketing if you're an
entrepreneur you can't afford to mow
your lawn now here's where this all
started for me I've been mentored by a
few different billionaires over the
course of my career and the first one I
I went to him and I said you know I want
to achieve I want to move forward you've
had all the success what do I do
how do I break out how do I create more
success for myself he said Eric how much
do you want to make in a year give me a
number I said well a million a year
sounds good you know two commas a
million dollars a year that sounds like
it would be you know a great life he
said fine he said that's a good start
let's let's break that down to make a
million dollars a year you would have to
earn approximately $500 an hour in your
work time $500 an hour in your work time
in order to be able to earn a million
dollars a year he said Eric is there a
task that you can do in your business
that will earn you $500 an hour overtime
and went well in network marketing
there actually is if I'm in front of a
prospect if I'm telling the story if I'm
sharing the product I'm telling the
story I'm sharing the opportunity I'm
explaining the compensation play
I'm with a prospect helping them
understand what it is that I have to
offer if I'm with that prospect that
overtime equals five hundred dollars an
hour or better that was my experience I
just didn't spend that much time in
front of that many prospects right I
would get my my life was busy with
everything else I said yeah yeah I said
yes I have that activity he said fine he
said take every activity that you are
doing that that that you that can be
done by someone else
number one the activities that can be
done by someone else number one number
two is pay it is worth less than $500 an
hour and number three isn't something
that's jeopardizing your family or your
values and have somebody else do it so I
said so wait a minute so I mow my lawn
you tell me I can't mow my lawn he said
you can mow your lawn but mowing your
lawn is minimum wage activity if you
want to sell your hour for minimum wage
and there's a task you could do
somewhere else that's paying $500 an
hour why would you do that call it
$15.00 an hour to mow your lawn and you
have a task that you that you could get
500 if you thought of prospects every
time you mow your lawn you lose 485
dollars and I went Wow
I thought I was saving money but money
might not know it was costing me money
to mow my lawn so here's what I did I
took inventory of every part of my life
I currently and for decades now have not
done tasks of under $500 an hour and
less it was something with my family and
less it was something that I chose to do
that was quality with the relationships
of my life I'm talking about work time
I'm talking about time things tasks that
I could do that don't impact my
relationships okay so I don't mold along
I don't clean the pool I don't clean out
the garage I don't get groceries I don't
clean the house and they're doing that
stuff you know in our families we have
people help us do those things and then
we focus our tasks our energy on the
highest producing activity possible
mastering your emotions and people ask
me sometimes it's like our emotions
important for entrepreneur managing
emotions does that and is that important
seems like it would be all discipline
and hard work well guess what will cause
you to stay disciplined and will cause
you to do the hard work is mastering
your emotion trying to figure out that
the triggers that cause you to act or
cause you to freeze and one of the most
interesting concepts and I learned this
from Tony Robbins he and I were talking
this last year several times about this
concept is so interesting and that is
what is your default emotion in other
words when poked when prodded when when
bored when either stimulated are not
stimulated what emotion is your go-to
emotion now for some people it's stress
entrepreneurs model a lot of
entrepreneurs like to oh I'm stressed
out I'm just stressed right now that's
their go-to emotion they go into their
mind and that is that's what they go to
as a default that's their neutral okay
some people use worry to worry about
something that might happen worried
about what somebody else might think
worry about some circumstance outside of
their control worry about what's going
on with their comp plan or worry about
what's happening with the product or
worrying about what's going on with the
international expansion or worrying
about decisions the team is making or
the company is making or worrying about
an event that's coming up or something
that's their default emotion some people
to fight their default emotion is anger
they want to fight they're looking for
an enemy all the time that's their
default emotion okay so we all have a
choice and we all have to decide what is
the default emotion that's going to
serve us and is the current one that we
have the one that's serving us the most
because if it's on a negative side
stress frustration doubt worry anger all
of those which many entrepreneurs have
if we if our default is there inside of
that space it's like putting a limiter
on our potential when we're in that
space you think we are attracting people
to us or do you think are we maybe
pushing some people away are we making
people want to be around us a lot or we
may be only attracting other angry
people or other stressed-out people that
we can relate to so there's a choice
there's another range of emotions now
that doesn't mean you can't bounce into
stress which is just fear you can you
can't bounce into anger or you know
defending somebody or or something you
can't bounce into frustration or worry
or doubt but what's the default where do
you go back to what Center what is
neutral for you and for me it was an
interesting exercise to kind of go
through this it's like wow because when
I was talking with Tony about it he was
saying that he has so much going on in
his life that it's very easy for stress
to become his default emotion so he
finally realized that no no that's a
choice I could choose to look at
something anything part of my life and
get stressed about it but my default
emotion could I replace that default
emotion for passion for joy for
happiness for gratitude those default
emotions what if your default emotion
was gratitude all the time what if it
was joy all the time now you might get
pushed
get stressed out for a minute but you
come back to joy you come back to
gratitude you come back to happiness
right you come back to passion and
there's a difference between passion and
anger if it's anger that's going to
repel a lot of people if it's passion
it's going to attract tons of people
into your life into your world so I want
you to think about what your default
emotion is maybe even write down what is
this emotion that you go to most when
poked when something doesn't go perfect
when something unexpected happen when
stressed
what is your default emote where you go
to there okay and just decide that on
the other side of that coin instead of
expectation and an anxiety it can be
appreciation and gratitude instead of
anger it could be passion instead of
worry and doubt it can be joy and peace
that's all going to be fine so we
control this we might not be able to
control the pain and we talked about
this that go for week reading mastery
we'll talk about this more and more we
might not be able to control physical
pain or mentally emotional pain but we
can choose suffering that's a choice the
pain might not be a choice but our
emotional state is a choice the one
thing that Tony told me that just
knocked me down is he and I both go up
on stage and we give a lot of energy and
we're video we're very enthusiastic
we're very energetic and then for me
when I get off the stage
I like I throttle back a bit I reset my
batteries so my stage energy is not my
default it's an exception so he told me
he said he said Eric the biggest change
happen in his life he said he said to me
when when we were doing an interview
this last year he said Eric the biggest
change happened to me in my life this
last year was I decided to take the guy
that's on stage I decided to take him
home with me and that was going to be my
new
people and I went Wow okay that's
something completely different
think about you and your best energetic
state your your most attractive your
most outgoing your most vibrant state
possible think about taking that person
home with you think about that being
your new normal think about that being
kind of the just everyday and the other
negative stuff is just kind of hearing
here and there it just comes and it goes
but you have a different default state
control that default state you start to
take control of your life all
entrepreneurs deal with this issue of
self-doubt of of challenge of difficulty
of struggle and I don't know what it is
for you I mean for me as so many things
went through my mind maybe this isn't
for me
maybe this just isn't my thing maybe
other people are made for this maybe I'm
not maybe
entrepreneurs need to be born because I
wasn't born an entrepreneur maybe I just
need to be realistic and just go get a
job maybe I don't have the discipline
for this or some days when I would just
say you know I get so discouraged with
people because I couldn't get people to
do the actions that I was going to do
maybe I'm just not a good enough leader
maybe the product isn't you know
valuable enough maybe the compensation
plan doesn't pay as much as I think it
should maybe I'm in a country or a part
of the world that is you know I feel is
more resistant to network marketing than
any other part of the world you know so
because of that I'm going to struggle or
whatever this is the list is so long
when it comes to reasons to check out
reasons to walk away you miss that rank
you push for that goal you get
embarrassed you you fall on your face in
front of your group you go try and do a
presentation it doesn't go very well you
drive across town you go across the
country even to do a meeting and nobody
shows up somebody in your company makes
you feel bad or makes you feel small
and because of that you get your
feelings hurt there's so many reasons to
quit and here's my message for you this
week if you're looking for a reason to
quit they're all there I just gave you a
whole bunch of them there's a whole menu
of reasons that you can choose and no
one will blame you you can say hey
because of this I decided not to do it
and that makes you feel better and that
explains it to the world and you move on
with your life there will always be a
reason to quit but if your dream is
strong enough there will always be a
reason to stay there will always be a
reason to push through there will always
be a reason to help others maybe it is
knowing that your product or service is
going to be have an impact on the world
and you can't let that go maybe if
you're rescuing people from desperate
lives maybe it's taking care of those
family members that that maybe can't
take care of themselves as well as maybe
you could help them do maybe it's giving
to the causes that are important to you
maybe it's seeing that next person your
group the the firelight up in their eyes
because of you because you persevered
because you worked when no one else was
watching because you decided to do
something that other people weren't
willing to do that sense of pride that
you did something that sense of pride
that you went through the battle but the
sense of pride that you stood for
something that's more valuable in my
opinion than living a life full of
regrets going through the challenge
understand the challenges what makes
something of you the challenges would
create something of you they say what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger I
think that's true what doesn't kill you
does make you stronger that doesn't mean
it doesn't hurt it hurts but it makes
you stronger and I will tell you it's to
struggle for the past since 1988 when I
got involved in network marketing it's
the struggle that forced me to become
the person that I
today and I'm proud of the person that I
am today without the struggle if it
would have been easy every single day I
wouldn't become much I've been just an
immature idiot running around with money
versus somebody who's learned and grown
and expanded and gotten better because
even though I had those days when I
wanted to quit I found a reason to stay
I found a reason to keep going I found a
reason to work through my fears I found
a way to conquer the struggle so I don't
know where I find you on this day when
this message finds you but if it's fine
if it's landing on you on a particularly
bad day just understand this there's
always a reason to quit but there's also
always a reason to stay
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Joshua to me GL
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what it Eric
states that had the biggest impact on
you what are you going to take from this
video that you're going to immediately
apply to your life or to your business
leave in the comments I'm going to join
in the discussion I just want to give a
quick shout out to total greatness thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book you're one word and posting that
fun picture to Instagram I really really
really appreciate it so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon
the Jim Rohn had a major impact on my
life by implanting these ideas the power
of an idea these ideas into my mind self
education will make you a fortune so
formal education everybody goes through
you kind of have to go through that but
what are you going to do after formal
education is done self education will
make you a fortune and I went Wow okay
he was the one that had me start because
I was back back then if I read any book
within about two pages I was ready to go
to sleep I was just exhausted you know
it's forget but he said Eric just start
by reading ten pages a day find a book
that interest you read ten pages a day
you can get through a 300 page book in a
month that you do that and start to
develop the discipline because I started
just listening to audio programs I did
not have any discipline to read and he
made me become a reader he said readers
are leaders self-education what are you
doing to improve your skills all the
time are you taking charge and I'm
probably one of things I'm most proud of
is how much I've educated myself since I
left formal education how much I've
educated my family books I've read how
many seminars I've gone to how many
skills I've worked on and developed how
many coaches I've had and mentors I've
had in my life in order to be able to
get better self education will make you
a fortune
formal education will make you a living
to get a paycheck self education you get
to be financially free I've read
probably two books a week on average for
the last
20-plus years so it's a lot of book a
lot of books
why because Jim Rohn taught me the self
education will make you a fortune and if
you stop growing
you start dying so I want to continue in
that growth pattern